here we are in a situation where again
intelligent people are
frankly pretending
that we still live in an america that's
defined by the stain of racism
in a way that if our grandparents could
hear us talking they would be appalled
that we would compare ourselves to them
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissin
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest today is
making a lot of ways at the moment he is
an associate professor at columbia
university and the author of work racism
john mcwhorter welcome to trigonometry
thanks for having me
it's a great pleasure to have you john
uh you've written a book that as i said
is making a lot of waves in the moment
at the moment uh a lot of our audience
are big fans of yours and know who you
are but there will be also a lot of
people particularly here in the uk who
are less familiar uh with your work tell
everybody a little bit about your story
who are you how are you where you are
what has been the journey through life
that leads you to be sitting here
talking to us
well actually what i am is i i study
academic linguistics i'm a linguist at
columbia university and the linguistics
work that i do
is not usually about race issues i'm not
i'm not somebody who only studies black
english or the like i'm just a
linguistics nerd really
but i have developed an alternate
commitment to
making certain arguments about race
because i think that the race debate in
our country and i think often in yours
as well
is based less on actually helping people
than on a certain kind of performance
and i'm worried that things have gone so
far in that direction that i feel like i
need to
speak up because
i feel that my views on these things are
shared by an awful lot of other black
people so the idea is not for me to
tilted windmills and being eccentric but
i feel like a certain on-the-ground view
about what
will help black america doesn't get
represented because of a certain
orthodoxy that is typical of two places
which are only a subset of society
academia and the media so really what i
am is a language geek
and i get detoured by also wearing
another hat as a race commentator which
i just sense as a duty because i feel
that a lot of people who feel the way i
do
refrain from saying these things in
public because they're afraid of getting
their feelings hurt i'm not and so here
we are that's my story
it's interesting let me ask you this
because as a fellow linguistic nerd i
was a i ran my own translation business
for about 10 years then became a
stand-up comedian another thing where
words are very important and how you
phrase things is very important and one
of the reasons i've been concerned about
you know we can talk about wokeness
which we're moving away from talking
about quite so much but this overall
trend there has been something quite
pernicious happening in terms of the
language that is used around all of this
stuff have you note is that one of the
ways you kind of got into you started oh
no it was purely the the race thing
i don't make that much sense no um
there are linguistic aspects to this but
the
the link between linguist me and raceme
is very thin so yeah obviously they're
language issues and people say well you
know john as a linguist what do you
think of the evolution of the term woke
etc and what i'm quietly thinking is it
has nothing to do with my linguistics
training i would think the same thing if
i were an architect and so no it's not
that i was dismayed by the language
people used talking about race i was
dismayed by what people say about race
and what it means for society
and that was quite distinct from me
thinking about adverbs and suffixes and
things like that really very little
relationship between the two things
and john what was the moment for you
where you felt compelled to write this
book
and before that compelled to make your
voice heard
well it was a gradual story and you know
it's at the point i'm 56 and so the
story is too long to be told because you
know nobody cares but me but in the
early 90s when i was in my 20s my
general feeling was
that black america had come a very very
long way
since the mid 60s the large civil rights
victories that happened then i thought
there's still things that need to be
done but miracles have happened over the
past 25 years and you should be thankful
for it gradually i realized that that
was not what the educated black person
was supposed to think and i noticed that
many people were nauseated by my sense
that there was any cause for celebration
that i didn't think of myself as living
in the same america as 1960 except that
maybe manners had changed i didn't like
that i i didn't understand why i was
having so many unpleasant conversations
and if anything differentiated me from
some others in that situation and i was
hardly alone it's that i thought what
really gets me is that the people who
refuse to admit that there's been real
progress and to feel it and to live it
and to stop talking as if it's 1960. the
people like this are intelligent and
they're sane
and they're nice i wasn't inclined to
think these people are crazy
i wasn't inclined to think these people
are trying to line their pockets or
manipulate white people i thought no
they're normal and i thought and so am i
what is creating the difference in view
here and so i just started analyzing it
analytically maybe in the same way as i
was trained as a linguist to analyze
language analytically but it wasn't the
way people were talking about race it
was what they were saying about it and
how they felt and so one thing
led to another and a lot of it was
serendipity but i wound up writing a
book called losing the race
in 2000 um that started with a piece
that i wrote for a kind of proto blog
site which i only wrote because i happen
to be working in linguistics on my first
language books for the public with a
publisher that happened to have that
blog site all of it just you know one
thing leads to another and you just have
to basically show up but that book
losing the race was a minor
bestseller and it put me on the map as
the the contrarian one of the
contrarians to go to about race and much
to my surprise over the past 21 years
people are still
asking me my views about those things
and so i end up having two jobs and i've
kept up with the linguistics but you
know constantine's you'll understand
that is not something the general public
is usually as interested in as hot
button issues like race and so i do the
linguistics sort of in private and then
the race stuff gets out there more so it
was a random story based on my just not
liking disorder linguistics is about
problem solving for me race is about
problem solving and for me
the idea that i was supposed to think
that i'm living in 1960 when it was 1991
was a problem to be solved
and john you say it was a problem to be
solved dare i say that the problem has
got significantly worse since 1991
yeah it has and i
really regret that when barack obama was
elected
i thought that it was an indication that
yes racism exists
but
something is really significant when a
black man can be elected president and
twice
it didn't have the effect that it should
have because around the same time social
media became default and social media
whips people up into extremist and
tribalist views and that's both on the
right and on the left and part of that
was calling attention to the
relationship between black people and
the cops which is important but it was
brought to attention in a rather
distorted way with this new social media
and as a result here we are in a
situation where again
intelligent people are
frankly pretending
that we still live in an america that's
defined by the stain of racism
in a way that if our grandparents could
hear us talking they would be appalled
that we would compare ourselves to them
and social media does not help the
pandemic has certainly
brought people inside of themselves and
whipped groups up together because
everybody was lonely
so yeah it hasn't changed that much i'm
i'm sad to think that i know i don't
even have to wonder there are 22 23 year
old middle-class educated black people
now who are in college wondering why
they're having unpleasant conversations
with people who refuse to admit anything
has changed my my friend and colleague
coleman hughes who is not yet 30 and has
the same feelings i do had that
experience he basically had the same
experience that i had where he
understands that things are so different
now that we need to ask a whole
different set of questions and was told
by a great many people that he was a
moral pervert for thinking so he's
having the same experience i had when i
was his age so no it hasn't changed the
way i wish it had yeah and john we've
had
the coleman hughes your friend glenn
lowry uh larry elder we've had all all
the people here in the uk we've spoken
to former england footballer john barnes
we've talked about this issue a lot
because
we're genuinely curious and we're trying
to understand but i suppose there comes
a point and i feel that certainly
francis and i have reached that where we
kind of know where we stand then we the
information is out there if you want it
you can go and watch our interviews you
can go and watch a bunch of other stuff
but what do we do about this what do we
actually do to improve because i think
you're right social media is the thing
that has made it so much worse and
probably
changed the direction of travel i think
we were doing better and better and then
social media came in would you agree
with that definitely yeah right
so so what what the hell did we other
than other than smashing twitter to
pieces which i think we'd all happily do
at this point what else do we do
well it's at the point where if you
sense that somebody is exaggerating
you have to stop i don't mean you too
personally but
one has to stop
thinking that there must be something
wrong with you
if somebody is exaggerating about race
chances are that that is true
and
socially maybe you have to pretend to
agree socially maybe you can step around
that person but
that person who's talking about white
privilege and white supremacy as if it
was 100 years ago and refuses to budge
that kind of person we have to step
around them and that's a lot of what
woke racism is about you can't engage
somebody on that because they've built
their whole identity around it the white
ones and the black ones step around them
you can't let them run the show you have
to get used to telling them no when they
want to turn an institution upside down
and i think we need to focus on the
things that black people actually need
which i'm afraid are less charismatic to
talk about than talking about something
as abstract as eliminating white
supremacy but that's why in the book i
write about ending the war on drugs on
promoting vocational education in a new
way
on making sure that poor black kids are
actually taught to read properly which
is more important than it sounds those
are the things that will turn things
around
down on the ground in the real world
which is really different from this
prayer circle pseudo marxist routine
that we're being taught has to happen
before anything real goes on
many people insist and this is people
you know from you know ordinary people
who just you know watch a lot of tv to
people who read too many books and
everything in between people think we
must have this conversation where white
people acknowledge before anything can
happen no
that's not true that's something that
we're told but that's hardly a settled
question how much do people need to
realize that's not how civil rights
activism has ever worked in the past
basically what white people need to know
they know it's at the point where now
it's time to go out in the world and do
the hard stuff that isn't as much fun
as wagging fingers in people's faces and
that's what i'm trying to get at in woke
racism
but this is a problem isn't it john this
idea that you know that you can
these people what they do is they go on
social media and they preach and they
say about you know how we need to reach
this new utopia but nobody wants to do
the hard work very few people want to go
into a classroom in the inner city where
it's
having done it myself where it's really
tough to teach and you don't get a lot
of money for it or you know you you go
and work on things like initiatives like
knife crime you go and become a youth
worker these are difficult things to do
it's far easier to go on social media
and just say what a great person you are
and how you want a rainbow in every
classroom
yeah i mean i think a lot of people's
view on this is that it'll be easier to
teach those kids in the classroom
if you eliminate white supremacy by
white people learning their complicity
and the way things are now and and
notice there's an ellipsis there
most people would be hard-pressed to say
and what what after this realization
comes what are you saying they're going
to do and are you talking about
something that would take a hundred
years because that's remarkably
unimaginative and that's the problem so
yes people like to go on twitter and
strike poses
showing that they're good people but
that's different from actually facing
and dealing with what conditions are
actually like out there and let's say
that those conditions are there because
of something you can call systemic
racism but often undoing what's going on
is not going to be a matter of changing
something called racism which i think a
lot of people would enjoy because it
feels like you're slapping a bigot in
the face really society is more
complicated than that and that's the
problem the twitter version of all of
this can't acknowledge those
complexities
and speaking of complexities you just
mentioned the term systemic racism there
does it exist do you do you think there
are areas of
society particularly in the united
states where there are systemic
structures that treat different races
differently
yeah there are there are things that
it's harder to do
if you are black because of certain
things that are baked into the system a
lot of it is based on racism in the past
as opposed to the present and then there
are some things that you might even
trace to
bias today you might say that in health
care there does seem to be a sense that
black people don't suffer as much pain
and yet that's that's real i i accept
those studies all those things fall
under the heading of systemic racism but
most of the things that are systemic
racism i don't like the term but the
phenomena definitely exists racial
inequities a lot of those things can't
be solved by doing something called
eliminating racism so it's not that i
don't think those things exist
it's interesting
many people seem to think that i'm
saying there's no problem that's not it
the issue is what you do
about the problem so for example
i'm guessing this is just just my guess
because i don't know larry elder that
well anymore but my guess is that larry
elder would say let's just stop talking
about systemic racism these things
aren't real just [ __ ] up and get out
there and deal that's not what i'm
saying that that's expecting too much of
people if you ask me that's not how
human beings operate if you don't know
how to deal if you've never been around
anybody who dealt you've got to be
taught how to deal the occasional person
teaches themselves how to deal and they
become larry elder but most people can't
do that but the thing is going out and
undoing the racism
is not going to solve say for example
the attitude that many black kids have
towards school because of racism 50 and
60 years ago you can't undo the racism
you have to undo how the black kids feel
and it's not about
changing white teachers attitudes for a
lot of people if it's not going to be
about changing white teachers attitudes
by giving conference papers and doing
twitter posts about white teachers
subtle racism well that's no fun because
that's not undoing the racism what that
means is that the kids stay exactly
where they are that won't do that's the
point of the book
well and particularly on the teaching
point i mean it strikes me that the last
thing you'd want to do if you want to
help kids of white teachers is make the
white teachers super uh concerned about
the way they use words and all of that
instead
instead of giving them the robust
support they need to teach the kids what
the kids need to learn right
yeah they should teach the kids what the
kids need to learn and there's this
fashionable idea that we're supposed to
look away from that and think of new
ways that are sensitized to the
conditions that the kids come from but
isn't it interesting that back in the
day no one thought of that and in many
circumstances the education of even poor
black kids was better it's treated as a
settled question that teaching must be
infused with a very subtle and very
thorough awareness that a poor black kid
isn't the same as a middle-class white
kid and it's always just verging on
saying that poor black kids can't learn
as well but no that hasn't been proven
it's just that it feels good to think
that way if your central goal is showing
that you know racism exists which is
different from actually making life
better for somebody who is of a race
this to me is john and i'm sure you you
might agree with this is the bigotry of
low expectations when i was a teacher
you know the consultants would come in
and they would say to me see the thing
is mr foster with your boys you can't
expect them to do what girls do when it
comes to reading when it comes to
sitting still when it comes to
concentration and i'm just remember
thinking to myself well once you have
that attitude to a certain section of
society they don't
they're absolutely doomed because then
they will play up to that and you're
offering kids an easy way out because
once a child has an easy way out the
vast majority of them are going to take
it see to me they're crippling these
children before they have a chance to
even walk and you know the thing is
that's absolutely true
and the person who tells you that cannot
point
to any studies or even any logic that
shows that things are better when you
don't require people to sit still when
you don't require people to do their
best where are the studies that show
that people learn more and do better
when less is expected of them because
they come from less than perfect homes
nowhere it would never occur to anybody
that they would have to prove it it's
just a matter of what it feels good to
say
that won't do
hey francis do you like books i only
like comics that's why my favorite
publication is the guardian it's true no
one does satire and parody like they do
so did you have a brilliant satirical
book for me yes it's a book by one of
our fans scott biceno and it's called
identity crisis it has been described as
1984 with jokes so it is like the
guardian no no no mate it's
intentionally funny so in present day
north west london it tracks the personal
journey of cocksure city boy dave
dalston through a period in which the
government has decided to define
everyone by their ego profile by a
document called the id card it's a
rollercoaster ride through cancellation
redemption and spiritual enlightenment
the author has been a fan of
trigonometry from the very start and he
has drawn a lot of inspiration from its
conversations so if you're a fan of
trigonometry then you're going to love
this book anton we are getting our 10
percent aren't we
check it out on amazon guys the link is
in the description below
and john one of the things that strikes
me about this because i'm i was born in
the soviet union i'm originally from
russia
i'm sort of white but i'm also not
exactly
i was not born here my ancestors didn't
own slaves in fact my ancestors were
slaves in in the russian empire and in
nazi germany etc etc so to me
i have this visceral instinctive
reaction when people start telling me
that i'm guilty of stuff or i need to
acknowledge stuff or i need to apologize
for stuff it seems counterproductive to
me it doesn't strike me as the way to to
bring people along and i worry about it
for myself because i don't want that to
radicalize me into opposing things that
actually need to be done and i feel like
that maybe has happened over the last
couple of years because
this way of approaching it does push
people into corners so how do we how do
we avoid that while still having the
conversation that we need to have well
there needs to be and i haven't thought
deeply about this yet i haven't thought
deeply about a lot of things but there
needs to be a reassessment of this
notion of complicitness because yeah the
the
standard issue answered to you is that
yes you arrived here from somewhere else
but you are now participating in and
benefiting from a system and therefore
you are abstractly complicit in the
oppression of people by systemic racism
even if you have a history somewhere
else and we all know that that argument
is forced
there are people who are going to enjoy
and embrace that argument because they
have other imperatives but most people
never will that's never going to work
that is never going to compel a critical
mass of society and we need to just
start facing it and realizing that if
we're going to move ahead we need to try
something else that complicitness
argument really jumped the rails in the
united states starting in the teens
and it's an interesting idea but to push
it too far especially with as many
immigrant people as we have in this
country including children of immigrants
not to mention immigrants themselves it
will never compel a critical mass of
people and it's not because the people
are racist it's because life is complex
and we all have our individual
identities and stories a lot of the race
debate that we have now
is predicated as if it were 1960 when it
was highly oversimplified to say it even
then but there were white people and
there were black people in some places
there were some latinos there was a
handful of asians except in a few places
in the country and god knows what else
there was and there was the idea that
immigrants from say the czech republic
etc well czechoslovakia at the time they
assimilated quickly so nobody thought of
them as a foreign element beyond their
first generation so you had white people
and black people that's not true now
there are latinos getting to be more of
them than black people since the
immigration act of 1965 so very many
people in this country come from very
different places black people are just a
sliver at this point and the
conversation that we're having is
basically becoming
what do we owe that sliver of the
american population who were descendants
of african slaves a very long time ago
that's going to have ever less purchase
upon say the korean grandmother it just
it isn't going to work
and
that is so true but the problem is with
that conversation the more you talk
about it the more you realize there is
no solution to it and the more we just
go around in circles
and the less is able to be done the less
we're able to move forward
yeah it worries me because there needs
to be a proactive agenda
and instead for example you think about
the current administration in this
country and i have no
no damning complaints about the biden
administration so far i think it's too
early to prognosticate especially given
that we're still dealing with the
pandemic but i think that if biden and
kamala harris wanted to do something
about race i'm afraid that in terms of
what's considered the proper optics
what they would do was invite you know
ibram kendy to the white house to say
some things and whatever he said would
make sense to him but wouldn't have much
to do with what would actually
change lives on the ground in terms of
people who are informed about policy
people who are informed about politics
and the like so there'll be these
pictures taken
of
writers who have a certain clout nicole
hannah jones will be one of them and the
thing is nothing would happen
is the problem and i haven't the
slightest desire to be asked to the
white house is not me it's that it would
be people who were more interested in
doing real things on the ground such as
elected officials who actually are
showing interesting results in their
cities those are the people who should
be asked about what black america needs
but instead it's going to be people who
have a message that america must be made
aware that it needs to you know stand up
to its ideals america needs to
understand that all black problems are
due to racism in some fashion none of
which changes anything that's yeah that
does worry me very much
because that's the problem isn't it that
we platform people or hate that term but
we turned these people into celebrities
without actually analyzing the quality
of their ideas
because once you listen to the quality
of these ideas as someone who comes from
venezuela and has seen what's happened
when you abolish capitalism i mean to
tell you they're not very [ __ ] good
excuse my language
yeah
and of course the idea is it wasn't
tried properly you know that's that's
always the idea all of these people are
interested in flavors they're interested
in postures they're interested in a kind
of performance because they think it's a
necessary prelude to change
that is not a settled question change
happens without those things and yeah we
need a whole different set
of people who are embraced as
celebrities in that way and i say again
no one will believe me but i i have to
say my truth my real self
is somebody who reads
books like this
this is a book about russian profanity
and i've been thoroughly enjoying it
don't need a book john i can help you
out with that no problem
it's gorgeous how much of it there is
but that's what i want to do i want to
sit at home and do that i'm not
interested in being quote unquote a
celebrity but there need to be
celebrities in that sense who are about
here's what i did right and you don't
see enough of that because that's not
considered sexy enough that bothers me
and that
you know the language point i tried to
make too earlier we didn't quite get to
the position but when francis said we
platformed these people and then
corrected himself
that's the sort of thing that i was
referring to where
language has been used for political
purposes and i we saw this in the soviet
union it's actually a very powerful
thing i would argue john where words no
longer have the meaning that they
actually have in the dictionary so for
example uh when you talk about an
inclusive space which these people often
do what they actually mean is the space
where people like the three of us would
be excluded from right but it's called
an inclusive space when you talk about
diversity it's not about actual
diversity it's about skin color variety
or sexuality variety it's not the same
thing as genuine diversity so
my question to you would be
given how institutionalized all of these
ideas have now become you talk about
someone going to the white house well i
would put it to you that it wouldn't
really make any difference who went to
the white house because at the end of
the day the democratic party the
institutions of the media and other
organizations that deal with all of this
they are so now they all of this stuff
is so embedded i don't even know that
anyone speaking censors you do for
example if you were in a nightmare of
yours to be invited to the white house
and have to answer some of these
questions
you would make any difference because
it's so institutionalized is that a
concern
yeah it is a concern and i think what
we're really talking about
is
changing the national conversation
slowly and it's easier to believe that
change doesn't happen than to
acknowledge that it happens slowly and i
think that can happen i think that's one
of the advantages of social media and so
for example i don't feel muzzled i don't
feel like i'm not heard if i want to say
something i can say it and it's out
there i feel that people are listening
and so there's contention but i don't
feel like the other view of black issues
is not
is is somehow um suppressed you know
coleman hughes made you know forbes
magazines um category of you know people
to watch under 30. that wouldn't have
happened 10 years ago and so things are
things are not what they could be
but it's going to be a slow business of
changing what people think of as the
norm it's changing the overton window so
to speak well let me just push back a
little bit because i would say to your
argument at least for for devil's
advocate purposes that coleman hughes is
the larry elder example that you gave me
before he's an
intelligent charismatic good-looking
young man
who who has a very soft way with these
words but we we get the same in comedy
which is our world right uh famous
comedians the ricky gervases the bill
birds others might say there is no
problem with free speech and comedy i
can say what i want to my theater or to
my stadium full of people and that is
true if you're ricky gervais and if
you're bill burr you can but if you're a
newer comic coming up the ranks the the
entire thing looks different because you
have a lot less power and i would argue
yes a tenured professor or or a standout
young man like coleman hughes sure
they're not muzzled there are a lot
awful lot of people i would put it to
you john the a are muzzled and b are
self-muslim
well oh there's no doubt about that and
so for example in academia which of
course i know best i know that muslin is
the default
most people don't think the way you'd
think academics think in terms of the
typical op-ed in terms of what you see
on social media but nobody wants to be
called a white supremacist on twitter
that's the students that's the
professors that is many journalists i
would say that daily
often several times daily but at least
once daily i hear from somebody
who is within some body of of people who
says that they agree with the sorts of
things i say and they're usually not
conservatives they're not right-wingers
say i get it thank you for speaking for
me but i could not dare to say these
things to the people that i work with
that is that is normal without a doubt
but
on the other hand i think that people
like coleman people like me
had less purchase
upon the media say 10
years ago i think it's slowly
getting better now the question is what
would you know the iceberg breaks off
what would be
the metric that shows that something had
really happened and
it's not going to be somebody writing
something in the sky but i think that
the conversation is such let's try this
the conversation is such that i sense
that the people on the hard hard left
sometimes feel like they're on the ropes
they feel like the other people are
irritants at this point whereas 10 years
ago they often pretended that people
like me didn't exist i like to see signs
of that
so you think the direction of travel is
positive
so my
slowly my worry is jon is
i don't know how
that is
is still a good thing if you see what i
mean when i look around at everything
everything has been politicized
everything has been racialized do we not
do you not think that it's too little
too late at this point
well to tell you the truth it depends on
what organs we're thinking about
i'm afraid that academia at least in
america is lost
because this kind of person is getting
to the point where they're going to be
making all of the hiring decisions i'm
watching
my own field for example where people
under 40 are being led by people who
think this way and i'm not sure that
anything can be done about it i have
literally realized that i'm going to age
out of a field that is nothing like the
one that i joined in terms of its
political
commitments and i'm sure people are
feeling that way in sociology and
musicology and history and from what i
hear although i hope this is alarmist in
some
stem subjects in terms of what you get
in journalism what kind of discussion
that you get it depends on what you call
journalism but for example i hate to
have it be about me but notice that the
new york times is letting me publish
things twice a week nobody would have
thought that
that would have happened say even a year
ago i never thought that i would write
for the times the times never ignored me
i wrote for the times in one way or
another probably once or twice a year
but a regular gig i would never
have dreamed and it's because of i think
a general pushback against the excesses
of what you might call wokeness these
days and i don't think that that is an
isolated instance in terms of whose
voices are out there and whether or not
they're listened to so for example
another one because i'm i live in my own
head and so i only know me
master class you know you can learn how
to cook you can learn hungarian etc
there's a master class that is about
race issues now they've got nicole
hannah jones they've got cornell west
they've got you know the usual suspects
doing their thing very well then they
also invited me now i'm kind of the odd
one out but they invited me that master
class two years ago would have been only
cornell west and nicole hannah jones and
the usual there's a message getting out
there that to not think like nicole
hannah jones i hate bringing her up too
much does not make you a moral pervert
that's something i feel i feel that
coming and so i'm seeing a pushback
against what happened in june 2020 and i
hope that it can push things back at
least to the way they were in 2019 but
maybe it shows you what a desperate
situation we're in that i'm now
nostalgic for 2019. no i think we're all
nostalgic for 2019 john
i think that's that's a real problem
yeah
barely barely the world has changed a
lot since it's been like 10 years yeah
john it's a refreshing conversation can
i you can ask you something that is
curious to me because neither francis or
i are on the right
uh or frankly on the left at this point
where somewhere sort of ambiguously in
the middle trying to work what we think
out issue by issue
why is this
race conversation such a right versus
left thing
it isn't
if you ask me
the
day of the black conservative for real
passed about 15 years ago
the list of people that
you used to see then most of those
people we don't hear from that much
anymore this is not a dis but
shelby steele
armstrong williams
until recently frankly larry elder i
mean now he's acquiring a new prominence
and all power to him but for a while he
was somebody you thought more about in
o4 than than now and i only mentioned
that to say that the people who are
actual card carrying black conservatives
the media definitely stop paying
attention to them in the in the mid in
the mid-aughts it's not that they're not
there but you know jason riley these are
great people but they end up talking
mostly to themselves
often glenn lowry is
a very good friend of mine and one of
the smartest people i know and but also
kind of an eccentric as a black
conservative really he's just glenn
essentially i think really what we're
talking about is the center such as me
and the hard left and the fight is over
whether the hard left is somehow the
heart of black issues because of slavery
and jim crow and redlining i think the
real question is why can't there be a
centrist way of looking at black issues
that isn't seen as some sort of
right-wing adjacent fantasy and i'm
seeing that conversation
as one that is progressing more
constructively than i would have
expected but yeah right left doesn't
quite make sense we're not talking about
cornell west versus shelby steele
frankly shelby steele who was my hero
but shelby steele lost that battle the
media just stopped paying attention but
now it's about center and left i think
well let me follow up on that because
there's something you keep talking about
which is i find very interesting which
is black america and that that used to
be a phrase you used to hear a lot
then you heard a bit less and i think
maybe now you're starting to hear it
more and
i am someone
who always thought from as an outsider
perspective and this is probably
extremely idealistic and naive which i
am prone to sometimes but the american
dream the american idea was
that in the words of barack obama there
is no black america there is no white
america you are an american and that is
the thing that defines you and as long
as you subscribe to the american values
you are that but you are quite i think
insistent on using that term and
addressing that audience so do you are
you someone who thinks that
a little bit of identity politics in
that way is is necessary is a good thing
is a way to reach people is just matches
your belief like what is your take on
all of that john
constantine you're catching me in um
[Music]
in
something that is a bit of a pose
you're right
what you what you suspect is correct
i'm saying black america
and i'm saying it because
to reach most black people who are
interested in this sort of thing
one should say that
um especially
because
there is a sense which i do not agree
with but that i figure you can't cut
through immediately and you have to
choose your battles
all of black america is united in having
an antagonistic relationship to the cops
the idea is that the cops kill black men
and so whatever conditions you're in
that is supposed to be something that
you deal with whenever you leave your
house
i honestly think that is vastly
exaggerated i think the statistics do
not support the idea that the cops
disproportionately murder black men for
reasons i've written about often the
cops murder too many men in general it's
not just a black thing nevertheless that
position is so fiercely held what i
found in the 90s when i thought why are
so many people exaggerating the main
reason was the cops i found oh
this is what's on people's minds
you have to pick your battles carefully
you have to do things in sequence
so yes i say black america the truth
am i being a bit of a phony in that yes
i'm thinking about crafting a message
the truth
is and i learned this from glenn lowry
back in the 90s and it's still true
about a third of the black community
needs serious help the other two thirds
life isn't perfect but the battle
is one and i find myself thinking
you know i am
there's a
seafood restaurant everybody's going to
say oh this is anecdotal but then again
if somebody on the hard left tells one
story that's considered testimony to the
history of the world there's a seafood
restaurant that i go to occasionally and
like many restaurants like that the food
is overpriced you know you get this
fried [ __ ] and you spend like a hundred
dollars and somehow you can't yeah it
sounds great
it's wonderful
it's that kind and it's too expensive
and i always notice when i'm there
because it's in the bronx on the beach
there are a lot of black people at it
and it's expensive you know you're
drinking your your bad wine you can't
get out of there without spending 120
and yet it is very popular with black
people and it's not only black people
who are there because somebody graduated
and they're only going to do it once you
can tell they they hang out there these
are ordinary bronx black people wearing
velour track suits etc they can afford
to eat at this place and they're not
unique that it's a core black community
who are doing just fine now the reason
i'm a phony is because if you talk to
two out of three of those people they
would still say the police
are against us and so okay we can eat
this shrimp and spend 120 dollars living
middle class lives but still we could
get knocked over the head by the police
just like the poor person i think that
that's exaggerated but i can't convince
them of that it runs too deep so yeah
you've caught me out there what i'm
really thinking about is what used to be
called the ghetto but i call this black
america as a rhetorical convenience i
feel like i have to but you're right
that makes sense the reason i bring it
up sorry francis i just want to finish
this the reason i bring it up is
i am
i am skeptical that we can ever come
together
as
people of different ethnicities if we
don't buy into the ideal that i naively
perhaps believe in
and
i wonder whether in the process of
attempting to reach people
and
playing to those concerns
we maybe sometimes forget that we can't
live together as one people if we're so
focused on our ethnic identities that's
a concern for me
what do you think about that
you are correct
but
you have to slow walk that
because there are people who simply
can't hear it
yes and notice what happens to thomas
chatterton williams who we haven't
talked about yet but thomas understands
that we've got to get past this race
idea because you know the way we think
about race is as if we were strom
thurmond it really is absolutely
ridiculous a smart child could figure
out how silly this is we've got to get
beyond this idea of race balkanizing in
that way race as an identity
but wow
and yeah i don't mean now i'm gonna
sound like i'm essentializing if you
grow up black you realize that for an
awful lot of black people
to question
that issue of whether you're black or
not especially if you've grown up
fortunate as it used to be called and
you talk like this
it is very hard for people like that not
to hear you as saying that you think
you're better than them
and once you have to pick your battles
and so i want to talk first about what
will help real people and maybe say
please stop exaggerating
stop disrespecting our ancestors then we
can get into must you think of your
color as defining you when really most
of us can afford to think we're just
americans
eating our fried shrimp and spending too
much money we're all doing the same
thing
that's going to have to happen slowly
and you know what i mean by slowly
another generation
30
years
it's not going to work now it just makes
people too upset is my thought
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website well if you do then easy
dns are the company for you easy dns is
the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be council culture d
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows a bit about
that so will you in a second easy dns
have rock-solid network infrastructure
and incredible customer support they're
in your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you'd know about that
move your domains and websites over to
easy dns right now all you've got to do
is head over to easydns.com
forward slash triggered and use our
promo code which is of course triggered
as well and you will get 50 off the
initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy that tells you
everything you need to know about
technology privacy and censorship
you know something john when in 2019 i
wouldn't really describe myself as a
conspiracy theorist the more i've gone
through this pandemic the more i've seen
things that haven't really made sense
and
dictates that my government have given
which
are completely nonsensical
is there a part of you that looks at all
this stuff and go
this is just glorified divide and
conquer
no
we're bees
everybody is a bee we're doing what we
need to do they're doing what they need
to do there are aggregate effects that
nobody
intended
i don't know how you would identify a
divide and conquer mentality
as anything deliberate nobody says it or
at least they don't write it down
i'm not inclined to think that they're
discussing it in private spaces it's the
way it ends up looking
because there are such shallow but
powerful emotional benefits to tribalism
and
shallow emotional benefits to being
white and encouraging that tribalism out
of a sense not of divide and conquer but
of showing that you're not a bad person
it's a religion so yeah that's i'm not
inclined to think of conspiracy theories
and we always say it's it's a religion
why do you think that particularly
oh because a religious framework is the
only way that a lot of this stuff makes
sense you have a stray white cop who
kills the occasional person
almost always in indefensible ways
the same person who got killed that way
was often in much more danger of being
killed by a black man in his own
community in much much much more danger
and yet the national discourse is much
more upset about the white cop
than about what that black guy is in
more danger of dying of
that makes no sense whatsoever unless
you see a commitment to showing that you
know racism exists that is so furious
so much a part of identity
that it resists facts and logic that to
me
is religious thought it's part of many
religions to let logic go and then the
chasing heretics the white privilege as
original sin
the fact that you're not supposed to ask
too many questions all of that falls out
naturally from it but i honestly believe
and i'm taking a certain amount of heat
the idea being that my religious analogy
is simplistic or that i should just call
it an ideology but no no it it the
religious analysis works i fully think
that a naive anthropologist who didn't
know of language and the labels that we
use would see
the way the worksters have been behaving
since two years ago as indistinguishable
from pentecostalism i don't think they'd
see any difference they would apply the
same words and it also helps understand
why a person can be so confoundingly
mean when you question their beliefs
about these things you're questioning
them you're questioning their basic
ethical commitment you're questioning
their religion that's when somebody gets
that upset it's like saying jesus
doesn't love you that's going to make
somebody angry same thing here so yeah
it really does it helps me make sense
of what otherwise can make you mad and i
don't want to be mad
and are there positives to this religion
john
no
not
the religious degree of it no i mean
when it gets to be a religion it ends up
hurting black people because you're more
concerned with showing things than
actually
helping someone it'd be nice if people
were deeply committed to helping black
people in a religious sort of way that
would be a that would be an offshoot
religion to this one so yeah the one
that we have
no
i i would like to see it gone but it
won't go away so we just have to work
around the people who think that way
john that makes perfect sense listen i
know you've got to go in in about five
minutes so uh we will ask you the last
question on the main interview and then
do a couple of questions for our
supporters only so the last question we
always ask on the show and you actually
haven't been warned of this uh so i'm
curious to see what he says and this
doesn't have to be related to anything
we've been talking about is what is the
one thing we're not talking about as a
society that we really should be
my answer to that is
really mundane
well it's not that we're not talking
about it i don't think we talk about
climate change enough
i feel like
in 10 years
it's going to be at the point where
we're wondering why we were talking
about woke racism etc when the planet
was about to burn up i really worry
about that but you want something more
underground than that um
i mean to be fair with you john in this
country we talk about climate change an
awful lot i promise you that
[Laughter]
yeah i mean it's not that it's not
talked about i sometimes worry that
we're all going to think we should have
talked about it even more but what do we
not talk about um
i wish
that science were more interested
in finding a cure for clinical
obesity
because i feel like it wouldn't be that
hard
given what can now happen
it's not considered as important as some
other things and i guess i understand
why but
i watch people who
have that condition and often it's not
because they eat too much
or sometimes it is but you can't stop
eating too much
and i think to myself wow
i would hate to be that person i don't
think that it's their fault
and i wish that there were a more
concerted solution to that i think about
it all the time i'm not sure why obesity
has never been a personal problem of
mine
but
watching the way people eat and the way
people in
non-western countries are beginning to
eat the same way that that seems to be a
way people start eating when prosperity
comes in watching what's happening in
some parts of china or on some
polynesian islands i know that seems
like
an eccentric thing that i'm just kind of
bringing up to sound fresh but it has
always touched me deeply that
people end up
ruining their bodies through no fault of
their own because of the way food is in
modern societies i wish that could be
solved that is my honest answer to that
and a very good one of that uh john
we're going to do a couple of questions
for locals after we wrap up here but i
thoroughly recommend everybody get the
book uh work racism and uh if there's
any way people can follow you online
john and keep up with your work where's
the best place to do that
um i'm kind of low tech on that i'm on
twitter but i don't spend my life on it
the way many people do i write a piece
for the times twice a week which often
reflects whatever's on my mind and it's
not always
race um i don't have a website i'm not
i'm not that type read my books
well we do recommend that you do thank
you so much for your time john we'll do
a couple of locals questions in a second
thank you all of you uh for watching and
listening we'll see you very soon with
another brilliant episode like this one
or raw show all of them go at 7pm uk
time and for those of you who like your
trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button so that you never miss
another fantastic episode and if you
believe that the work we do here at
trigonometry is important support us by
joining our locals community using the
link below